the photographer who took a picture
along the Mexico border that appeared on
the front pages of newspapers around the
world is now sharing the story behind
this picture we tracked down the Reuters
photographer his name is Kim Jung hoon
who took the picture of a mother and her
two daughters running away from a
smoking teargas canister on Sunday near
the us-mexico border he said that he
noticed the kids were barefoot and in
diapers he spoke to Mireya Villarreal
about that moment what was it about them
Kim that struck you what was it about
them that made you take that picture
when I saw the woman and then two girls
I think maybe that can tear a story
because I had a chance to talk to it
many migrants and most of them say they
want better life also they won't give a
better future to their children they say
that's that's one of the region they
want to go to the United States so
that's why I mean in that you know
hectic and chaotic situation maybe just
let me just focus on them Reuters
reporter spoke to a woman yesterday in a
shelter she tried to claim asylum at the
US border on Sunday but was among the
migrants blocked by Mexican police some
rushed the fence prompting the Border
Patrol to fire tear gas Customs and
Border Protection Commissioner Kevin
McKellen and said the gas helps stop and
adults from throwing rocks and he said
it was quote unfortunate that women and
children were affected it's a reminder
that behind every picture is a story
exactly right